benoa Strasse in berlin is a lively and
colorful neighborhood in the German
capital but a generation ago it was part
of the death strip and no-man's land
created by the Berlin Wall anyone who
tried to escape to West Berlin was shot
by East German border guards on patrol
but that's all in the past
I love living here she says because I
have so many friends
today's been our Strasse is a melting
pot with eastern and western Germans
living alongside citizens from around
the world and Galica vista tells us
she's counted families of eight
nationalities in her apartment house 18
children 22 adults she says and we all
love each other but this is what
residents saw in August 1961 as
construction of the wall began neighbors
friends and whole families were divided
by a concrete scar
apartment blocks on one side of banished
while so were in the eastern sector
directly on the border with West Berlin
windows or turned into brick walls as
the facades became part of the wall just
one step away this sidewalk was in West
Berlin in the mid-1970s the apartment
buildings were demolished as the East
German police state refined its security
system that planted landmines and spring
gun devices anti-tank barriers along
with paved strips for Jeep patrols and
every few hundred metres the infamous
watch towers all part of an effort to
discourage illegal immigration still
many escape attempts were made here
because the death strip was relatively
narrow today the old patrol path remains
running between construction sites and
pricy apartments there's lots of room to
play
it's a favorite place for Angelica's son
Jimmy she's from eastern Germany and was
living in Dresden when the wall fell
twenty four years ago the patrol path
lies behind her apartment with banished
Vasa out in front from her rooftop
terrace she has a magnificent view of
what used to be the capital of East
Germany
her apartment building sits directly on
the former no-man's land today the
central location makes this area prime
real estate we pay a visit to an Getty
Calista and her family her husband hails
from a village in Bavaria in what used
to be West Germany
they have two children Jimmy is the
younger one
Angelica says the construction of her
new home was a real adventure she
visited the site every day with her
older son Gianni as the basement was
being dug out they discovered the
foundation of the building that once
stood on this property
you know actually oh sure I was calm it
was like an archaeological dig she says
you can see the water and heating
connections and the pipes that's Johnny
she adds Angelica Hans and the boys
introduce us to the neighbors Anka and
Daniel they have two children as well
another neighbor Annabelle is also there
with her daughter's they moved into the
neighborhood about a year ago the locals
agree it was a good idea to breathe new
life into the former death strip they
also admit that real estate prices in
banish'd casa were rock-bottom when they
bought this property and they had no
idea just how hard it would be to build
here it was five years before they could
move in the old Border Patrol path was a
particular problem building inspectors
wouldn't allowed the construction crane
to be parked there Daniel says it took a
while to realize the true significance
of what they were doing he says the
family came to terms with an unusual
situation building in a place that was
stigmatized for decades
but he reasons that wasn't always the
case apartment houses existed here
before World War two and were torn down
when the wall became further entrenched
this empty space was left over he says
and that's why he thinks it was
reasonable to rebuild family homes
Angelica adds that they experience the
history of this place every day the past
has become part of their daily life in
this day and age this was banished Wassa
in the mid-1960s
no sign of life just a cold concrete
wall dominating what had been once a
lively residential district the stately
Fasano scare show a reconciliation
Church was demolished in 1985 to give
soldiers in the watchtowers unimpeded
views of the border
today the Berlin Wall memorial has been
erected as a place of remembrance a
Chapel of reconciliation sits where the
old church once stood
inside prayers are sent for those who
were killed trying to escape from
totalitarian East Germany yaagh Hilda
planned is the son of a former pastor at
the reconciliation Church he spent his
childhood on Bernauer Strasse right on
the border his family moved when the
wall was built he tells us it feels
strange to walk along Bernauer Strasse
now there's no wall no police demanding
documents no one denying people entrance
it's amazing he says that he can stand
here now free to say and think whatever
he wants but see food heydo plant is a
frequent visitor to the Berlin Wall
memorial he says it must be hard to
imagine for those who never experienced
the wall firsthand but this place
contains powerful reminders of how
locals dealt with the stark division
between East and West for example some
East Germans even dug tunnels below
ground to try and escape to the west
some lost their friends and loved ones
while others found the loves of their
lives shows us a place that played an
important role in his life Bernauer
Strasse number 2 this he says is the
address of the woman who would become
his wife
here's her bedroom the living room and
the kitchen the Memorial Centre has
recorded the story of lagina and Yerger
Ida blonde for posterity
hidden shows us a photograph of him and
his brother looking out towards banish'd
lesson number ten from East Berlin to
West Berlin from one country to another
they could still converse with their
friends he explains even though the wall
was already under construction back at
Angelica's place she's about to meet
with the rest of the property owners
we've invited your Hildebrandt
if one fair she informs the children
that mr. Hildebrand will tell them
stories about the wall and the place
they've chosen to build their new homes
this place in its history has brought
together children and adults Eastern and
Western Germans and citizens from around
the world who now live here
moving images from a bygone era helped
to bring the past back to life that
place is right around the corner she
says this is been washed glossa in the
1960s before the apartment buildings
were torn down this film clip shows a
drama that captured global attention a
77 year old woman jumping to freedom
it's one of the countless stories over
nearly 40 years then on November 9th
1989 everything changed
heydo plan tells us that he finally
walked with his wife through the
Brandenburg Gate and embraced in a kiss
right there that he'll never forget it
was overpowering he says we never
thought we'd see this in our lifetime
one guest wonders what he thinks about
all the building projects in what used
to be the no-man's land
odd response that the wall can't remain
everywhere that history is fleeting he
adds it was clear that the wall would
eventually fall and he considers himself
lucky to have witnessed the event
firsthand on that historic evening he
hoped that in a quarter century nothing
would be left of it she called me
through this one memory will never fade
those shot and killed trying to flee for
many banal Strasse
was the best hope for escaping to
freedom
the children are impressed for them it's
a story of adventure and they want to
figure out how many bedsheets it would
take to rappel from a window to the
ground
Angelica counts five sheets and all
everyone is surprised they thought it
would be many more but five is the
number because one is needed to anchor
the rest of them someone asks if she
could imagine rappelling down the side
of the building herself oh yes she
replies been washed Vasa has been
transformed from its former status as a
death strip and a symbol of the division
between East and West Berlin but that's
all in the past what counts for the
children is the here and now
you